joining us now a man who just finished
his first draft as the new general
manager of the baltimore ravens although
he's worked with the ravens since they
became the ravens back in 1996 he is
ravens gm eric decosta eric welcome back
to the program how are you
hi mike i'm doing good how are you doing
i'm doing great and i don't understand
this this is an age where people don't
stay in one job for very long especially
in the nfl where there is a constant
rotation and movement and trying to get
a promotion and just trying to hold on
to the job you have how do you manage to
stay 23 years with the same team
my wife
my wife mike she's from the area she
loves baltimore we've got family here
she's got her whole family her mom her
sisters her cousins my children go to
school here and baltimore's become my
second home i grew up in boston but
baltimore i like the proximity to major
cities and it's just become a place that
we like
but that's just half the equation the
other half of it is doing the job well
enough that you can stay there for 23
years and i i know you're going to have
a certain level of humility here but
you've clearly done a great job or you
wouldn't have been permitted to continue
to work for the ravens all these years
in a competitive industry that that is a
rarity that someone can make at 23 years
without at some point someone saying
yeah it's time for a change
well we've been fortunate you know uh
continuity is a big word uh in this
organization it started with mr modell
and it continued with steve bashady and
we're an organization we've been around
24 years
we've only had three head coaches and
now we've had two
general managers and it just works you
know i i've come to work every day i see
the same faces i've worked with most of
these people in this organization i'm
not unique
we've all worked together for 24 years
our video staff our training staff
you know pr
operations we've all a lot of us have
been here now 24 years and that's a
great feeling just being together
familiarity and uh and just being on the
same page
yeah and you know it sounds easy when
you think about it but so many teams out
there give into that temptation for the
quick fix and they end up making things
worse and maybe half the battle is
ensuring that there is continuity
because year in and year out you deepen
the relationships and people understand
each other and a lot of things that
maybe trip up teams where they're trying
to get used to new personalities that's
just something you really have to deal
with
well i think that's a great point and as
we studied years ago as we began to look
at really successful organizations
the one thing that we noticed that sort
of all these organizations shared is
staying together building something from
the bottom building a culture it's very
hard to build a culture when you blow
things up every single year and that was
something that was appealing to mr
modell and also steve bashady
unfortunately we've all benefited from
that
what's harder for you hearing it from
your boston people that you work for the
ravens or hearing it from baltimore
people you're from boston
oh man i'd say the second you know uh
my my boston
family they understand that i'm doing
this as a job
but the uh the baltimore fans sometimes
have a tough time
handling my allegiances to some of the
boston sports teams
especially the red sox and the celtics
and the bruins and so i have to be
really careful uh especially when i go
to orioles games that i'm not wearing
anything that might get me in trouble
[Laughter]
over the years your name came up from
time to time as a guy who was under
consideration for gm jobs elsewhere and
i think at one point we all realized
this guy's staying put and he's going to
become the gm of the ravens at some
point but how close did you ever come
was there a time where you and you don't
have to say when or where but was there
a time where you thought you know what
this is the time where i'm going to go
somewhere else so i can be my own guy
and run my own team
well i think there are a couple times
where you start to wander a little bit
and think about it and the opportunity
may be really attractive and you look at
ownership you look at fan base you look
at the organization in general you look
at the players that they have on the
team salary cap situation everything
kind of looks good
and so what i would do is basically
sleep on it think about it and wake up
the next day and realize that i was
crazy and that the best opportunity for
me was right in front of my face
and that you know the most enjoyment
that i get is when the baltimore ravens
win football games and so for me
you know i would think about it i would
flirt in my own mind a little bit i
would consider it but quite honestly
mike going back to 2007 that was the
first indication that i had that i would
be the gm in baltimore and once steve
bashady and i had that conversation
and we realized that it was a good fit
for him and also for me there was really
no turning back
you know it's been such a gradual
transition i i have written down here to
ask you what's the biggest difference
between your job now as the gm and what
it was as assistant gm but but i feel
like it probably is no change because
it's been such a long time coming and
it's been such a gradual process that
it's just a matter of dropping the
assistant from the title
well you know it's been a little bit of
a transition i think that uh you know
fortunately i've been blessed
you know ozzy is such a has such a
humility about him in such a spirit that
he has basically taken me it taught me
so many different things that i've had
the opportunity over the last five years
to really learn the job which a lot of
my
contemporaries they don't have that
luxury to actually learn the job before
they get the job they get the job and
then have to learn the job so in my
situation the biggest change has
probably been
i don't have as much time to watch tape
anymore because people are coming into
my office quite a bit with different
situations and questions and they need
help help and guidance of various things
so my day is now broken up into many
more segments than when i was the
assistant gm or the director of player
personality college guiding director i
could sit behind my desk and watch tay
for seven hours so i've had to be more
creative with my time and find ways to
do my evaluations knowing that my days
are going to be you know some and far
between
and if you don't have as much time to
watch tape that means you have to trust
other people's evaluations is that a
difficult thing to do
well i mean i think if you've ever
really run a draft for years like i have
you your comfort level is is quite
honestly being in charge of the draft
and that's a that's a blessing but also
a curse in some respects so
fortunately we've got some really really
talented people that work with me joe
ortiz
george coquinas pat moriarty vince
newsom guys like that that i know i can
count on to get the majority of the work
done what i try to do is be a good
listener and trust the scouts and the
people and the coaching staff
and that we work together to make the
best decisions
gets back to what we're talking about
earlier too with continuity it's easier
to trust the people you know because on
top of taking on a new job you don't
have to worry about some new person
whose work you don't know that all of a
sudden you have to blindly trust
that's a great point and so as i've
joked in the past if i go downstairs and
say that the lunch is a six seven lunch
everybody that i work with knows it's a
great lunch so they're all going to run
downstairs and get the food because we
speak the same language we know the
grading scale we've been together for
years and years and years there's no
guesswork there's very little training
involved we just really work together
well what's a six seven lunch mean if
it's on a scale of ten that doesn't
sound like a great lunch
but we're not on a scale of 10 mikes
we're on a scale of 8.
that's a first year starter that's a
first year starter lunch
that's the lunch that's going to come in
right away
and you're going to want that lunch
people are going to get in line for that
lunch
yeah you want that lunch to come in
right away you don't want that lunch to
go out right away that's for damn sure
all right um you traded down this year
before you got receiver marquis brown
at 25 the deal with the eagles and
surely you wanted marquis brown before
you traded down you thought you could
trade down and still get them i think
you've said that in the aftermath of
round one what's that that two picks
like while you're waiting and
waiting for someone to jump you or one
of the teams in front of you to take the
guy you want
well you know i did have a little bit of
apprehension about the eagles coming up
just because marquis brown seemed like
an eagles type of player and that we had
heard his name connected to them a
little bit
so that was probably the pressure point
for me
the texans we we felt were probably
going to take an offensive lineman which
they did so
i felt like once marquis got past philly
at 22
we'd have a chance to to get him
but
it is a scary feeling we had another
player that we really liked as well so
as long as you look at your list you see
how many spots you are away and you have
that many players that you would be
interested in drafting you're okay he
was at the top for us the attraction of
getting a fourth-round pick and a
six-round pick made a lot of sense for
us where we were as a team and
roster-wise so it was an easy trade to
make
but it makes it even better listen
sometimes we've made trades in the past
we've gone back we make a lot of trades
and we've lost out on the guy that we
wanted so it does happen
but this year worked out really really
well for us
is the etiquette to not ask the team
that's trading up into your spot who
they're gonna take because i remember a
couple of years ago when the 49ers and
the bears flip-flop the 49ers didn't
know who the bears were taking it to
when the 49ers went to three and the
bears may have taken their guide is it
does it ever happen where there's a
we'll do this trade as long as we're
clear that you're not taking our guy
i've heard that before i've heard teams
ask that question
you know i think that we haven't done
that
you know in the last however many years
we've just kind of winged it because i
think would you
i mean my mindset is when you make a
decision to trade
you're making an organizational decision
and you're you're on board with that
decision
all bets are off i mean it could be a
situation where team actually tells you
that they're taking somebody and they're
taking somebody else uh we've had
situations in the past where teams
haven't always been honest with us in
various situations
so you know i haven't asked that
question i suppose i could have asked
howie roseman that question he might
have given me the answer but you know he
could have also been on the clock and
traded i mean he might have gotten a 22
and somebody else comes along and says
hey we want that pick i mean our phone
was ringing multiple teams were calling
us
so you know i think once you make that
decision to make the trade once you make
that decision to trade away from the
pick
you're not in control anymore you take
the picture gonna get and you move on
what's the biggest challenge of drafting
a guy like marquis brown who had the
foot injury was able to do nothing
pre-draft
you're relying on his tape you can't do
the apples to apples comparisons what's
the biggest challenge of of feeling good
about still making that pick in round
one
probably that i mean you just basically
answered your own question i mean a guy
hasn't worked out he hasn't run a 40.
you've got to go strictly off the tape
you've got to go strictly off what
people say about him
and fortunately we've always based our
evaluations of players on their tape
first and foremost so we love this tape
we thought he was an explosive player
dynamic college football player whose
skill set really did fit our team and
what we're trying to be as an offense
and so there's always a little bit of
apprehension anytime a guy doesn't work
out it seems like more and more nowadays
players aren't working out quite as much
so we go back to the tape we trust our
people we get multiple looks we talk to
people at school and we make our
assessment
the other receiver you drafted this guy
was the 30th pick in round three miles
boy can you ran a 4-4-2 a couple of fast
receivers how much of that speed desire
is influenced by
the changing quarterback the type of
offense you're running now and just any
other adjustment that's happened as you
go from joe flacco to lamar jackson
well i think lamar factors in we want to
put weapons around him his skill set
being probably the fastest player on the
field in most games
it makes it tougher for teams to
basically you know
basically all focus on him he doesn't
have quite the bull's-eye maybe on his
chest if these guys end up being
legitimate players
i think in general mike you know we want
to be the fastest team we can football
has changed
you know back in 2009 2010 we used to
play the steelers and those games were
like you know blood and guts smash mouth
football
and football has changed
it's changed a lot we play these dynamic
offenses we play the steelers twice a
year we play the bengals uh with the
speed that they have on offense we
played the chiefs this year we played
the saints this year
you know we've played the rams we
scrimmaged against the rams this past uh
training camp and i got a chance to see
all their wonderful talent that they
have
and
football has become in many ways a track
meet
and speed wins it's very tough to defend
and we've sort of gotten into that game
late but we think time is right for us
with lamar to put some weapons around
him some fast guys around him to stress
defenses
see that cuts against what everyone now
believes about the ravens offense people
are calling it a throwback i'm looking
at lamar's passing numbers last year he
never threw more than 25 passes in any
one game are are you suggesting that
that those numbers are expected to go up
this year
well i think we've
proven or we've shown that we have a
power running attack we've shown that
we're able to run the football
effectively i think that
over the last seven eight games of the
season last year we led the league in
russian
but
we're aware of that as well we're aware
of the fact that teams are now going to
look at us
as a run first run primarily team
and we want to make it tougher for those
defenses to put eight or nine guys in
the box
so does that mean we're going to wing
the ball down the field all the time no
i don't think we'll do that but now
we've got a lot of different players
that give us the chance to create
mismatches in different ways with a guy
like hollywood brown you've got a guy
that can play in the backfield he could
play in the slot he can play outside he
can run reverses you can run screens
with him he can go deep with a guy like
miles boykin he's got the speed to go
downfield and stretch the defense with
his size and his skill set we've got
willie snead to play inside in the slot
we've got chris moore and some of these
other younger guys that we've drafted
that we feel really good about we've got
some really good tight ends and mark
andrews hayden hurst on the first round
draft pick last year these guys can go
up and catch the ball and make plays as
well so now when you take those guys and
you put them with our running backs mark
ingram who we signed this year just
edwards kenneth dixon
justice hill who we drafted we feel like
we've got a really intriguing set of
play makers to help lamar move the ball
effectively
let me flip it over to december
defensive side of the ball you had
several guys leave via free agency eric
weddle was cut you know fans get nervous
when they see these recognizable names
leaving the team
what do you say to the folks who think
the defense is going to take a step back
because so many names people are
familiar with aren't going to be there
anymore
well i mean i understand their concern
and we're concerned about that as well
but we've been through this before we've
had
multiple times over the last however
many years 20 years i'd say where we've
had these sort of purges where we've
lost veteran players it happened in 2002
it happened in 2007. it's happened it
happened the year that we traded hello
to nada away
you know so it happened when we lost ray
lewis we lost ed reed
it's happened many times in baltimore
and the one constant is we've been able
to rebuild the defense pretty quickly
and stay strong and so in looking at our
defense i think we've got a really
really wonderful secondary a very
talented secondary with some outstanding
players i love our defensive line up
front we got michael pierce and brandon
williams two guys that can really play
the run and play stout in there we've
got some really good i think young
ascending linebackers and peanut and
warsaw and kenny young who we drafted
last year matt judon who we think is one
of the more intriguing outside
linebackers in football with his skill
set as a pass rusher and a young
outside player who can make plays
so the coverage not bare we had to make
some really tough decisions salary cap
related we knew the market would be
irrational in one sense
and we saw zadarius smith and t.j mosley
essentially get almost record type deals
at their positions
we decided to
make a very very tough decision with
eric weddle
and we wanted to bring
t sizzle back and it didn't work out he
had a choice to make he had another team
in the game in arizona and he decided to
go home and uh and play for arizona and
we wish him well along with eric along
with cj and zadarius those guys are all
outstanding players who play great
football for us they made decisions we
respect those decisions and we hope they
really thrive
you know maybe more surprising than any
of the departures the decision to lock
on to earl thomas and it was one of
those eric my reaction was you know what
this made sense all along we should have
seen this coming because it's like hand
in glove type of a fit earl thomas on
your team but you put a high value on
that position a big contract for earl
thomas how did you get to that point
where you knew that was the right move
well he's the guy that we've played
against i've always really really
admired him and when i thought about
ravens type defenders
in my mind that's real thomas and when
you think about his skill set when you
think about how he plays
you think about what he brings to the
table as a player but also a leader
that's el thomas he's the guy that makes
plays in the box down the field he's a
playmaker he wins games with his ability
to intercept passes he's a leader he's
played on really really good teams which
was intriguing for us the fact he's
played in so many big football games he
was a natural fit and so if we're going
to lose the terrell suggs if we're going
to lose an eric weddle if we're going to
lose a cj mosley we lose a lot of
leadership and a lot of skill it made a
lot of sense for us to bring earl thomas
into the fall to have him replace some
of what we lost
hey last one for you before i let you go
trace mcsorley drafted from penn state
quarterback and there's been a lot of
talk about other positions there's been
comparisons to julian edelman is he a
quarterback and only a quarterback with
the ravens or could he play other
positions
that's a great question i think he's a
football player and everything that that
entails i think his skill set is buried
in multiple we brought him in we spent a
day with him here in baltimore several
weeks ago
we worked him out as a quarterback
but this is a guy that he's fast he's
strong he's tough he's a playmaker he's
a football player and we've seen teams
for instance the new orleans saints at
pace and hell we've seen other teams
find ways to play with players like this
and they can help you win football games
so he fits our defense
fits our offense he fits special teams
he's got a great mentality he's a leader
he's highly competitive he's played in a
lot of big games and we're excited to
see what he can do
did you miss speak or did you intend to
say he fits our defense
i think he fits everything this guy's a
football player he pulls the ball away
he runs the ball well he's been a safety
he could probably return kicks he could
probably punt if we need him to punt
he's a talented kid he's super smart
he's highly competitive and uh we just
want to find his niche we're going to
carve out a niche for him
he gives us a lot of possibilities we
played against the saints this year we
got a chance to see what tayson hill
could do
first hand and uh when you got a guy
like that you can line up at quarterback
you can run with him he can throw the
football
he plays on the special teams as a
personal protector you can fake kicks
with them that's a weapon we're going to
try to use our guy the same way
well eric you you found your niche 23
years ago here's to 23 more
congratulations on all your success we
look forward to talking again soon
thanks mike i appreciate it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports